et de les améliorer progressivement,
pour les transformer en véhicules autonomes.
C'est un peu comme si je vous disais
que si je m'entraîne suffisamment à sauter, je pourrais voler un jour.
On doit faire les choses autrement.
Les systèmes d'assistance à la conduite sont différents des voitures autonomes
sur trois plans différents.
Je vais commencer par vous présenter notre expérience.
En 2013,
on a réalisé le premier test de notre véhicule autonome,
avec des passagers normaux.
Disons presque normaux - nos employés Google,
qui ne travaillaient pas sur le projet.
On leur donné la voiture,
et demandé de l'utiliser dans leur vie quotidienne.
Mais ce véhicule n'est pas encore vraiment autonome.
Ils doivent être concentrés
car ils sont dans un véhicule pilote.
On l'avait déjà beaucoup testé, mais il pouvait avoir un problème.
Les passagers ont reçu deux heures de formation.
Ils sont montés dans la voiture.
Leurs réactions furent stupéfiantes.
Ils voulaient acheter ce véhicule.
Tous nous ont affirmé adorer ça.
Un de nos passagers avait une Porsche. Le premier jour, il avait affirmé :
« C'est une idée stupide. A quoi pensez-vous ? »
Mais en fin de test, il avait changé d'avis : « J'en veux une !
Et tout le monde devrait en avoir une. Il y a tant de mauvais conducteurs. »
Nous buvions du petit lait.
Ensuite, on s'est intéressé aux actions des passagers.
Ce fut une révélation.
Mon passager préféré est un homme
qui jette un coup d'œil sur son téléphone, constate qu'il est presque à plat,
se retourne ainsi, et fouille son sac à dos.
Il sort son PC portable,
le pose sur le siège,
va dans son sac à dos à nouveau,
fouille et sort le câble pour recharger son téléphone.
Il le déroule, le branche sur sa machine, et sur son téléphone.
Son téléphone est en train de charger.
Pendant tout ce temps, il roule à 100 km/h sur l'autoroute.
Et voilà ! C'est incroyable.
Ça nous a fait réfléchir. Une évidence nous est apparue.
La fiabilité du conducteur est inversement proportionnelle
à la fiabilité de la technologie.
En améliorant les voitures progressivement,
on ne peut pas arriver à faire une avancée significative.
Permettez-moi de vous parler technique quelques instants.
En abscisse de ce graphique,
le nombre de fois qu'un véhicule freine inutilement.
On peut ignorer cet axe
car vous n'achèterez jamais une auto qui s'arrête à l'improviste
quand vous roulez en ville.
Sur l'ordonnée, le nombre de fois que le véhicule freine
quand il est supposé freiner, pour éviter un accident.
En bas à gauche, dans le coin,
on a les voitures conventionnelles.
Elle ne freine pas à votre place, elle ne fait rien de maladroit,
mais elle n'évite pas les accidents.
Quand on ajoute un système d'assistance à la conduite,
un système anti-collision, par exemple,
on augmente la technologie embarquée.
En voici la courbe. Le système a des propriétés spécifiques,
mais il n'évitera jamais tous les accidents.
Il n'en a pas la capacité.
Prenons un point au hasard sur la courbe.
Le système évite la moitié des accidents potentiels.
C'est formidable, non ?
On vient juste de réduire de moitié les accidents.
17 000 personnes qui ne meurent plus sur nos routes.
Mais avec une voiture autonome,
notre courbe doit ressembler à ça :
on a besoin d'embarquer plus de capteurs.
On choisit un point sur notre courbe,
où le véhicule n'aura jamais d'accident.
Il y en aura, mais avec une fréquence très basse.
Nous pourrions maintenant avoir une discussion,
sur la progressivité. Je parlerai de la règle « 80-20 »,
de combien il est difficile de passer à la 2e courbe.
Mais observons ça d'un autre angle, pendant un instant.
Regardons la fréquence avec laquelle la technologie doit agir correctement.
Ce point vert représente un système d'assistance à la conduite.
Il s'avère que les conducteurs, aux États-Unis,
commettent des erreurs qui entraînent un accident,
une fois tous les 160 000 km.
En revanche, un système de conduite autonome prend environ
10 décisions par seconde.
En d'autres mots,
on parle de 1 000 décisions sur 1,6 km.
Si on compare la différence,
on arrive à 100 millions.
C'est une magnitude de facteur 8.
C'est comme comparer ma vitesse de course
à la vitesse de la lumière.
Même si je m'entraîne beaucoup, je n'y arriverai jamais.
Il y a donc un ravin à traverser.
Enfin, comment le système gère-t-il l'incertitude ?
Ce piéton va peut-être traverser. Ou peut-être pas.
Je ne sais pas. Nos algorithmes non plus ne savent pas le prédire.
Si on a un système d'assistance à la conduite,
ça signifie qu'il ne va pas réagir,
car ce n'est pas acceptable qu'il freine inopinément.
Alors qu'un système autonome va détecter le piéton et dire :
« Je ne sais pas ce qu'il va faire,
je vais ralentir, observer, et réagir ensuite de manière adéquate. »
C'est donc bien plus sûr que n'importe quel système d'assistance.
Voilà pour les différences entre les deux.
Passons un peu de temps sur la vision de la voiture.
Voici notre véhicule.
D'abord, il se localise par rapport à son environnement,
en alignant la carte et les données des capteurs,
et ensuite, on ajoute ce que le véhicule voit en temps réel.
Les objets mauves qui apparaissent, ce sont les autres véhicules,
l'objet rouge, sur le côté, c'est un cycliste,
et au loin, vers le haut, si on est attentif,
on aperçoit des cônes.
On sait où se trouve la voiture à un moment précis.
Mais on doit faire mieux : on doit prédire ce qui va se passer.
Le pick-up en haut à droite, va changer de bande, vers la gauche,
parce que la route est barrée devant.
Il doit donc dégager.
C'est super de prédire ça.
Mais ce qu'on doit vraiment savoir, c'est ce que tout le monde pense.
C'est un peu plus compliqué.
On peut maintenant déterminer la réaction du véhicule sur le moment,
la trajectoire à suivre, sa vitesse d'accélération ou de décélération.
Ensuite, il s'agit juste de suivre le chemin :
tourner à gauche ou à droite, accélérer ou freiner.
En fin de compte, il ne reste que deux chiffres.
Est-ce vraiment difficile ?
Quand on a commencé le projet en 2009,
notre système ressemblait à ça :
on voit notre voiture au centre, et les autres objets sur la route,
Le véhicule doit comprendre sa position, et celle des autres véhicules.
C'est une compréhension géométrique du monde.
Dès qu'on a commencé à rouler en ville,
la difficulté a pris des proportions incroyables.
Il y a des piétons qui traversent devant, des voitures qui traversent,
et vont dans toutes les directions,
les feux, les passages piétons.
C'est extrêmement compliqué.
Dès qu'on a résolu ce problème,
le véhicule doit gérer les chantiers.
Voici les cônes à gauche, qui obligent à rouler à droite.
Ce n'est évidemment pas un chantier isolé.
On doit gérer les autres véhicules
qui négocient le même passage.
Si quelqu'un enfreint une règle, la police veille.
Et donc, notre voiture doit comprendre que ce gyroscope sur cette auto
signifie qu'il s'agit d'une voiture de police
Pareillement, la boîte orange, sur le côté,
c'est un bus scolaire.
On doit donc le gérer différemment.
Sur la route, les autres ont des attentes :
quand un cycliste lève le bras,
il s'attend à ce que les voitures lui cèdent le passage,
pour lui permettre de changer de voie.
Et quand un officier de police est sur la route,
notre véhicule doit savoir que ceci signifie l'arrêt,
et que ce signal l'invite à avancer.
Pour y arriver, on échange les données entre les véhicules.
Voici le premier modèle, imprécis :
quand un véhicule détecte un chantier,
il transmet l'information aux autres véhicules
pour éviter toute difficulté.
Mais on a une compréhension plus profonde.
On pourrait intégrer toutes les données détectées au fil du temps,
les centaines de milliers de piétons, de cyclistes,
et de véhicules sur les routes,
et analyser leur apparence
pour déduire les caractéristiques supposées
des autres véhicules, des autres piétons.
Plus important, on pourrait utiliser ça pour modéliser
nos prévisions sur leurs mouvements.
Ici, l'objet jaune est un piéton qui traverse devant nous.
L'objet bleu est un cycliste, et nous anticipons
qu'ils vont contourner la voiture sur la droite.
Un cycliste vient en sens opposé.
On sait qu'il va continuer tout droit et longer la route.
Une voiture tourne à droite,
dans un instant, une autre va s'engager dans le carrefour devant nous.
On peut anticiper ces comportements et les gérer avec prudence.
Ça marche très bien pour tout qu'on à déjà vu.
Mais il y a évidemment plein de choses inédites.
Il y a quelques semaines,
nos véhicules roulaient à Mountain View,
et voici ce qui est arrivé.
Une dame en chaise électrique
qui pourchassait un canard sur la route. (Rires)
En fait, il n'y a aucun paragraphe dans le code de la route
qui nous explique comment gérer ça.
Cependant, nos voitures y sont parvenues :
elles ont ralenti et roulé prudemment.
Il n'y a pas que les canards.
Cet oiseau vole juste devant nous. La voiture réagit en conséquence.
Voici un cycliste,
qu'on ne peut rencontrer qu'à Mountain View.
Bien entendu, il y a les autres conducteurs,
même s'ils sont tout petits.
A droite, quelqu'un va sauter de son camion vers nous.
Regardez à gauche, la voiture avec le cube vert, décide
de tourner à droite au tout dernier moment.
Au moment où on veut aller sur la bande du milieu
l'auto sur la gauche décide de faire pareil.
Une voiture brûle le feu rouge,
et continue sa route.
Ici de même, un cycliste brûle le feu.
Notre véhicule a géré ça en toute sécurité.
Il y a aussi plein de gens qui font je ne sais quoi,
parfois même sur la route, comme ce type, entre deux voitures autonomes.
On se demande à quoi pensent les gens !
(Rires)
Je vous ai montré beaucoup de choses.
je vais maintenant en décortiquer une.
Voici la scène avec le cycliste.
Sur l'image du bas, on constate qu'on ne peut pas encore voir le cycliste.
Mais la voiture peut : c'est l'objet bleu.
C'est possible grâce aux données du laser.
Ce n'est pas très facile à comprendre.
Je vais donc changer l'angle de vue pour l'observer.
Quand on a l'habitude de ces données,
on voit des points sur la courbe.
Juste ici. Le cube bleu, c'est le cycliste.
Notre feu est rouge.
Celui du cycliste vient de passer orange.
En louchant, on le devine sur l'image.
Le cycliste va quand même traverser le carrefour.
Notre feu passe au vert, celui du cycliste est rouge.
Nous anticipons que le vélo va continuer.
Malheureusement, les autres conducteurs ne sont pas aussi attentifs.
Ils démarrent, et heureusement pour tout le monde,
le cycliste réagit et les évite,
et arrive sain et sauf de l'autre côté.
A ce stade, nous démarrons.
Nous avons fait des progrès encourageants.
Aujourd'hui, nous sommes convaincus
que cette technologie ira sur le marché.
Nous réalisons tous les jours 5 millions de km de test sur simulateur.
Nos véhicules ont une sacrée expérience.
Nous avons hâte de voir cette technologie sur les routes.
Nous croyons que le chemin de la conduite autonome est le bon.
Pas celui de l'assistance à la conduite.
Il y a urgence.
Durant mon temps de parole,
34 personnes sont décédées sur les routes américaines.
Quand pourrons-nous l'utiliser ?
C'est une question difficile parce que le problème est complexe.
Voici mes deux garçons.
L'aîné à 11 ans. Dans 4 ans et demi,
il pourra obtenir son permis de conduire.
Avec mon équipe, je m'engage à faire tout pour que ça n'arrive pas.
Merci.
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
Chris Anderson : Chris, j'ai une question.
Christ Urmson : Vas-y !
CA: L'intelligence de tes véhicules est époustouflante.
C'est au sujet du débat entre assistance de conduite et conduite autonome,
il y a un véritable débat.
Certaines compagnies, comme Tesla,
font le pari de la conduite assistée.
Selon toi, c'est une impasse,
parce que c'est impossible d'améliorer au point de devenir autonome.
Un conducteur va penser que c'est sécurisant,
monter à l'arrière, et un accident monstrueux va arriver.
CU : C'est exact. Cela dit,
les systèmes d'assistance à la conduite continuent d'avoir beaucoup de valeur.
Ils sauvent beaucoup de vies.
Mais cette opportunité révolutionnaire est le seul chemin possible
pour permettre à des personnes comme Steve
de voyager et d'arriver à destination sain et sauf,
pour transformer nos villes,
et éliminer ces cratères urbains que sont les parkings.
CA: On va suivre tes progrès très attentivement.
Merci beaucoup, Chris. CU: Merci. (Applaudissements)